what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to be breaking down episode 13 of
attack on titan season 4
in which the aegiris continued their
takeover of parodies island and zeke's
secret plan was exposed
today i'll be talking about all the
parts i felt needed explaining including
the importance of the
and wine falco's dilemma and the full
reason why sash's father spared gabby's
life
before we begin be sure to hit that sub
button as we are closing in on the 250k
mark and as usual i'd appreciate if you
dropped a like as it does help out the
video
okay so episode 13 was called children
of the forest and it starts off with a
flashback to the peaceful village of
ragako
where zeke turned all the residents into
titans four years ago
due to zeke's royal blood he has certain
abilities that are similar to the
founding titan
with one of them being that he can turn
any alien into a pure titan
once they ingest his spinal fluid he did
this during the battle of shiganshina
and at the battle of fort slava but i
think we always assumed that those
eldins were given spinal fluid
injections
what this flashback shows us is that the
fluid can be administered in multiple
ways
since the residents inhaled a white gas
containing it this proves that no matter
what form the spinal fluid is in
all it takes is one particle of this
stuff to enter an aldian system
and zeke's scream will turn them into a
pure titan throughout the season we've
seen high-ranking officers of the
military police drinking this mali and
wine
as well as members of the survey corps
who are currently watching over zeke
the problem here is that much like the
gas used to destroy ragako
this wine contains zeke's spine of fluid
so that means that if he's within range
he can titanize anyone who drank it not
only that
but the beast titan has been shown to
have control over the titans he creates
meaning that right now he could summon a
personal titan army if he wanted to
as an ackerman levi would likely be
immune from zeke's scream if he drank
the wine
as back in season 3 it was stated that
the acumens had some kind of special
immunity when it came to the power of
the titans
this immunity meant that their minds
couldn't be wiped by the power of the
founding titan
and presumably it also means that
they're immune to stuff like this
last episode we saw that hanji was
suspicious of why elena wanted malians
to work in restaurants
and now we have a solid answer on that
from the very beginning
elena knew that the wine was tainted and
she told malians like niccolo to serve
it to high-ranking military
officers as a result you now have mps
like nile
who consume this wine thinking it was
totally normal and are now
at the mercy of zeke one last thing on
this for now is that
during this opening scene zeke told levi
how eldians in ragako froze up
when they consumed his spinal fluid the
truth is that this was a lie that zeke
told to multiple people
so what we see in the flashback in this
part at least didn't actually happen
this was a genius move from zeke because
by convincing everyone that they'd
freeze up if they drank his spinal fluid
it meant that nobody ever suspected the
wine was contaminated
because why would they i mean if they're
just drinking the wine and they feel
perfectly normal
then they had nothing to suspect anyway
after the opening the anime switched
over to the fancy restaurant where
nicolo currently works
a few episodes ago he invited sash's
father to come and have a free meal
though he didn't imagine that he'd bring
four kids one wife and two warrior
candidates along with him
gabby and falco specifically came so
they could talk to nicolo after kaya
previously informed them that he was a
malian soldier
at this point in the episode the survey
court arrived whilst everyone was eating
because like i said
hanji was suspicious of why marlins were
made to work in restaurants
they wanted to ask nicolo some questions
to better understand elena's motivations
so he told him to wait in this room
until he was free to talk the reason
this room is special is because it's
usually reserved for mps
which is why the cupboard has one very
special drink from what jon said
we can tell that the malian wine must
have been popular among the officers
who've had it
and he jokingly picks it up nicolo then
aggressively snatches the bottle back
and there's a couple things i should
explain about this moment number one is
that
although nicolo didn't know for a fact
that the wine was contaminated
he strongly suspected it was so in this
scene he's actually trying to protect
jean and connie
at the same time though whilst he's
trying to protect them he also doesn't
want them to realize that the wine has
been tainted
so he pretends like the reason he took
it is because he still hates aldians
after three years on the island it's
pretty clear that nicolo does not
actually hate aldians
but the fact is that he needed to have
some excuse so they wouldn't ask too
many questions about why they can't
drink the wine
you may then be wondering why nicolo
continued to serve this wine if he no
longer hates aldians
and the truth is that there is a good
justification in the past
elena has been shown to have no mercy
when it comes to malians who don't
believe in her cause
in fact nicola witnessed her gun down
her superior officer
on the very first day they arrived on
parodies she was the one who told him to
sell the wine to mps and if i was him in
the same situation
i probably would have done it as well he
saved jean and connie not just because
he likes them
but also because they're not
high-ranking officers because those are
the people that elena initially told him
to target
if these two were military police then
there is a possibility that he would
have let them have it
as sash's family continued to enjoy the
food falco pretended to be ill
so that he and gabby could slip away
they then find nicolo in the cellar
where they begin talking to him as their
real selves
rather than the ben and mia aliases that
falco created
this is the moment when nicolo begins to
realize that gabby kills sasha
since back in the cemetery mikas had
told him how it was a young girl who
snuck on the airship that did it
back then nicolo knew it was a warrior
candidate and gabby straight up confirms
right here
that she is the candidate in question
despite being amalian
nicolo had an obvious affection towards
sasha with kaiju even theorizing that
the two of them were in love
while i personally don't think that
sasha and nicola were in a relationship
based on what he said at her grave
i do believe that at the very least she
was in love with his food
in any case falco already realized that
sasha might be the person that gabby
killed but he wasn't able to put the
pieces together until it was too late
by the time he tried to shut gabby up
nicolo himself had already realized that
gabby was the murderer
using the same bottle of wine that he
snatched earlier nicola were tempted to
smash gabby's head in
but luckily for her falco intervened the
kid was instantly knocked out cold
but the real predicament here is that a
drop of the tainted wine entered his
mouth
we already established that aldians only
need to consume the tiniest particle of
zeke's spinal fluid for it to work
meaning that this drop should do the job
in trying to defend gabby for the
millionth time
falco has unknowingly made himself one
of the people who could be titanized if
zeke chooses to do so
nicolo clearly regretted his mistake
here but that didn't stop him from
punching gabby in the face
which i feel like he did on behalf of
most of the attack on titan fandom
after taking gabby and falco upstairs
nicolo offers sasha's father the chance
to kill gabby himself
though because of all the noise the
survey caught in the room next door were
alerted to what's going on
it's interesting to note that in spite
of gabby's actions
none of sasha's friends in the survey
corps actually wanted revenge
later in the episode mikasa tries to
check that gabby is okay which shows
that there are not
really hard feelings around sasha's
death my guess is that number one
they're relatively decent people who
don't want to hurt kids and number two
perhaps the info they learnt about mali
over the years has made them realize
just how brainwashed these kids must be
anyhow nicolo holds falco hostage to try
and get a reaction out of gabby
as he explains why sasha was so
important to him and why her life meant
something
it was kind of funny to see gabby's
brain malfunctioning as she tried to
comprehend how himalian could care about
an eldian
nicolo humanizing sasha in this way was
seriously important
because from gabby's perspective all
aliens from the island are devils so to
hear this coming from mammalian
it will have some effect on her going
forward however something even more
impactful
was the fact that sasha's father decided
to spare gabby's life
gabby couldn't understand why he didn't
hate her for killing his daughter
and she also seemed quite regretful in
the hallway at the pain she had caused
their family
in normal circumstances the regular
gabby would never feel any type of
remorse
so she is starting to see the truth in a
way just like falco has
if you're interested why sash's father
spared gabby's life it all comes down to
ending the cycle of hatred that caused
these wars to start in the first place
when we look back at the whole timeline
the cycle of hatred began when the old
alien empire
conquered the world with titans those
years of dominance led malians to feel
hatred towards elder
which eventually caused mali to attack
the wars of paradise when they had the
power to do so
that attack on the walls led to aaron's
mother's death which grew his feelings
of hatred
and ultimately resulted in his merciless
attack on liberia
we then saw firsthand how eren's attack
fostered gabi's hatred for the aliens
even more
causing her to go on a suicide mission
just so she could kill as many devils
as possible the point is that the cycle
is literally never ending
as people are constantly trying to get
revenge for what was done to them
sasha's father knew that she was not
some kind of innocent civilian she was a
soldier who killed people
and was then killed herself so her death
was something that he was
on some level mentally prepared for and
he doesn't want to take revenge on gabby
because doing so would only continue the
cycle
from his perspective it is the duty of
adults to stop these things from
happening again
obviously from what we saw kaya did not
share those same sentiments
as i think she was especially hurt given
how she helped gaby and falco despite
knowing they were from mali the whole
time
while sasha's family were grieving
nicola dropped the absolute bombshell
that i mentioned earlier which is that
falco has likely been contaminated by
zeke's spinal fluid
earlier in the episode he of course
tried to hide this fact from the survey
core
but in this moment he exposes the truth
because he's trying to atone for what he
did to the warrior candidates
as a low-level soldier nicola was never
explicitly told that the winer zeke's
fluid in it
but he knew it was likely given the
context all of the survey ships were
packed with more wine than was necessary
and nicolo found it strange that elena
asked him to serve it to high-ranking
members of the military
mali also has a history when it comes to
using zeke's scream to destroy enemy
nations
so you can totally understand why nicolo
had his suspicions
back in the forest a few soldiers
informed levi about how the yeagers are
starting to take control of politics
within the walls
in case you maybe forgot hanji confirmed
last week that there are three soldiers
besides herself
that know zeke's location and these two
guys are part of that select few
they reveal that pixis is currently
working on a plan to have aaron eaton
which just goes to show that the fake
surrender we saw last week
was exactly that the captain has always
believed that aaron was humanity's best
hope for survival
so he can't really accept the fact that
after everything he's done after all the
times he's saved aaron
that the end result is that he's just
going to be eaten by someone else
in levi's mind the only person who
should be eaten is zeke
though obviously that is a bit difficult
right now the issue is is that if zeke
was to be eaten by someone without royal
blood
then parodies would not be able to use
the rumbling and if they can't use the
rumbling
then they have nothing to protect
themselves with against the forces of
mali who will be coming to destroy them
on the flip side zeke also can't be
eaten by someone with royal blood right
now
because the only person available is
hystoria and she is currently pregnant
so it's just not possible for the time
being
this means that regardless of what levi
wants the fact is that if either of the
two yeager brothers are going to be
eaten
the most viable candidate is aaron
meanwhile in the restaurant
onyankapon makes it clear that he had no
idea about the contaminated wine
proving that not all volunteers were in
on this plot from what we saw in this
episode
the only people who are 100 new are zeke
elena
flock and by extension aaron as well now
just because aaron knows about the wine
doesn't mean he wants to destroy
parodies like nicolo was theorizing
instead the wine can just be used as a
way to control the military
because naturally those in the military
do not want to be turned into titans
whilst gabby is in the other room armin
notes how she reminds him of eren
and speak of the devil eren literally
just appears as he's saying this
i honestly love how calmly eren walks in
like he was supposed to be here
but i guess this is how you walk when
you just have nothing to fear because of
the cut in his hand
it means aaron can go titan mode at any
moment and thanks to the warhammer
aaron can even use his titan powers in
enclosed spaces
the other jaegers storm the restaurant
and hold the survey core at gunpoint
because like aaron told them their
mission is to find zeke
hanji is one of the few people that
knows zeke's location and that's the
reason why they're here
although pixis offered to surrender
aaron chose not to accept that proposal
as he accurately suspected that they
were trying to betray him the igress
didn't trust that pixis is actually
willing to help them
so rather than risk being betrayed by
the military flock intends to make hanji
personally take them to zeke's location
flock begins to depart with the new
prisoners with hanji being the one that
will lead them to zeke
there are a couple reasons why aaron
isn't going with them with the first
being that he wants to chat with his old
best friends
i say old best friends because flock is
clearly his new bff
and right here aaron looks incredibly
tranquil his mood is contrasted by gabby
who was sitting across the table from
the man that massacred her hometown
so this really is quite a peculiar
meeting aaron has made everyone keep
their hands on the table so that no one
tries anything funny
but of course he is ready to go at a
moment's notice the second reason why
eren isn't going with the yagras
is due to the lack of trust that they
have in the military if eren was to join
them
then in theory hanji could lead them on
a wild goose chase and take them to a
location where eren could be ambushed
instead of risking that they can collect
zeke themselves and then once they get
him
the threat of the scream will be enough
to keep the military in check
one quick thing to mention is that griez
is another mulligan soldier
who works at the same restaurant with
nicolo he's the one that told the jagers
to come
as it's implied that elena gave him some
way of contacting them if necessary
when the survey court arrived earlier in
the episode that's when grize must have
sent the signal
and from then on it was only a matter of
time before the yagaris arrived
with that said that was my breakdown for
episode 13 of attack on titan season 4.
as usual i'd appreciate if you dropped a
like if you liked the video and let me
know in the comments what you thought of
the episode
until the next one peace out